without a doubt Oberyn Martell is the
best one-off character in Game of
Thrones and Bobby B exists so there's
tough competition for that title Oberyn
I think is the most universally likable
character in the entire show this is
because of his great personality with
unbreakable Charisma along with a deep
well of other lovable personality traits
then he's brought to life perfectly by
Pedro Pascal and this was really his
breakthrough performance as an actor
before this he had minor roles in
television so he proved himself here and
it opened a Gateway into getting better
roles it just seems like he plays Oprah
in effortlessly and with so much
confidence to the point that you
couldn't see anyone else as that
character the first area I want to
tackle for understanding why Oberyn is a
perfect character is the writing and
then we can go into more detail about
Pedro's performance and then the
external factors about the character
that makes him even better upon
re-watching all of oberyn's scenes I
realized each one of them introduces and
showcases a new personnel trades it
makes his scenes feel very efficient
because we keep learning new aspects
tied to the character going through his
scenes we have his opening where it's
shown he's a courageous Fearless badass
his scene with Tyrion shows him to be
vengeful he's able to swathly play
politics at Joffrey's wedding he's a
compassionate lover who wants to
experience all the desires in the world
he has strong composure and doesn't act
on impulse in the face of Tywin he's a
kind intellectual who writes poems and
treats myrcella with care the small
council meeting shows him to have an air
of Disobedience and with all of this
he's even able to be sincere with Tyrion
in the dungeons almost all of his scenes
are productive on a character
development level and even though
there's a Proficiency in character
development the writers don't compromise
any plots of elements and are able to
expertly do both like an example being
his first scene in which it gives you
the entire essence of Oberyn while also
explaining his entire motivation and
backstory so right away you understand
the character her the mountain raped
Elia and split her in half with his
great sword I feel like this isn't
something to take for granted because
there are so many other shows in which
characters have way more screen time
than Oberyn but yet they are
significantly more dull oberyn's scenes
are meticulously planned and aspects of
his character are always being revealed
to the viewer it makes all of his scenes
much more entertaining and thus makes
him even more alluring through all of
his screen time you're also searching
for any character flaws and negative
traits and that finally shows up in his
last scene during his fight with the
mountain he gets over confident and thus
becomes careless in the pursuit of the
truth so even though he's a very
colorful character with many likable
traits he's still a flawed individual
and that makes him Human by his final
scene it comes full circle and this
final trait finishes his character and
his overall Arc just a very efficient
setup and payoff in the course of only
eight episodes that's an achievement in
of itself from how great of a character
George was able to write in that short
amount of time another clever thing I
picked up on on rewatch was how much the
writers emphasized the mystery of Oberyn
all of his opening scenes generally
paint him as more of a villain because
he openly says that he hates the
Lannisters at the end of each of these
scenes they generally end with an open
threat like the way his first
interaction ends with Tyrion this is
also the first episode of this season so
at this point in the story you assume
that Oberyn will be a possible Catalyst
to blow up conflict in King's Landing
throughout the show we are taught not to
trust anyone so this new character
showing up according to things we
learned earlier and general story tropes
tells us that Oberyn is not to be
trusted especially since he openly made
his objective well known so the twists
in which he actually turns out to be a
good guy is that much more surprising
because he shattered our expectations of
this new mysterious character that in
this whole scene was brilliantly written
easily one of my favorite monologue
scenes that is imbued with so much
emotion up until this point Point we've
never seen Oberon in this more sensitive
light so seeing him have a moving scene
with Tyrion was special along with it
even adding in more backstory about how
Cersei and other people hyped up Tyrion
as being a hideous monster as a baby
when in reality he wasn't it makes for a
great point for Oberyn to sympathize
with Tyrion and him choosing to be his
Champion was one of the most uplifting
moments in Game of Thrones Tyrion at
this point in the story has utterly lost
and even his own brother and best friend
won't fight for him so Oberyn coming in
out of left field to help him was a
great twist which if you've been paying
attention this perfectly makes sense
within the story because of oberyn's
Vendetta against the mountain but yet it
doesn't come across as an obvious point
in the story because the mountain is so
menacing and terrifying to the point of
no one wanting to fight him so overall
this is really the turning point for
oberyn's character that really makes the
audience rally for him this is his
purpose within the show and now he's
extremely important the amount of stakes
tied to his character is drastically
surged in the upcoming Mountain fight
makes you hyped as hell from here we can
look at the mountain versus the Viper
scene and obviously it has some fun
action but what really floored me was
the writing the twist at the end where
Oberyn gets overconfident and gets
blindsided by his Vengeance for Tywin
and makes a misstep that cost him his
life is probably the most shocking twist
right behind the Red Wedding the reason
why this twist rocks you so hard is
because it was very unpredictable and
because of tyrion's Fate for the last
three seasons Turin has been the primary
protagonist in King's Landing so going
into this trial by combat you assume
that there is a fair chance that Tyrion
Will Survive given his importance along
with Oberon being this new and dominant
character so surely they won't kill him
right right then to even combat the
suspicion that Oberyn will lose they
actually make it to where he wins and
then in a freak accident he dies this is
literally the best outcome from her
writing perspective and I can't imagine
a better way to have written this scene
it's a roller coaster concern which you
experience the highs of winning and the
lows of losing it's a massive rug pull
just when you think all the danger is
gone it feels like George R Martin is
playing mind games with you because you
know the most logical twist will be for
Oberyn to win but then that in turn now
seems like a predictable outcome George
somehow accounts for this and blows us
away with what ends up happening along
with him obliterating the status quo of
the show because as an audience we
assume that Turin will return to what
he's been doing in King's Landing so by
completely sending Tyrion in an unknown
Direction it leaves the viewer not being
able to predict where the story goes and
thus this was the least expected outcome
another crazy thing is that Oprah not
killing the mountain is not contrived
Oberyn is trying to desperately question
the mountain for information and this
makes sense because this objective has
been established in multiple scenes in
order to subvert expectations in a
narrative it needs to make sense within
the story because here it works expertly
meanwhile in later Seasons it utterly
shatters the logic in order to pull off
Hollow shocking moments like rhaegal's
death scene being the biggest Defender
where Dany forgets about the iron Fleet
despite being reminded of it and getting
sniped out of the sky this may quote
unquote shock the viewer but it's met
with confusion and anger because it
compromises any realistic notion within
the story in essence it's and
Dave and Dan keep doing this throughout
season 7 and 8. so oberyn's final scene
is the literal opposite of this because
it's logical and is driven by two
amazing characters I know it took some
of the emphasis off of Oberyn and talked
about this overall scene but it clearly
wouldn't be possible without Oberyn the
reason why his death hit so hard is
because he was such a lovable character
who was taken away so soon his presence
was short and sweet and because of this
he stirred up a perfect character
because his time in the story has
absolutely no downtime or flaws like
it's a lot harder to call other
characters perfect considering their
trajectory for later seasons unless if
you just ignore their later Seasons
altogether another thing about oberyn's
scenes is that he contrasts really well
to certain characters and the writers
take advantage of that like one of my
favorite pairings was Oberyn talking to
Varys in the throne room oprin is a man
who loves pursuing desires and is
constantly indulging himself at every
opportunity he can get so this being
contrasted as someone who has no sexual
desires genuinely confounds Oberyn and
Varys even says that he's had no desires
even before being a eunuch this is the
anti-thesis as to how oberna operates
and their interaction because of this
was very engaging the part in the script
where open ask Varys what his true
desire is given his lack of sexual
ambition and all he does is look over at
the Iron Throne it's a genius point in
the scratch this kind of contrast can
also be seen in his small Council scene
what is a man who is so disobedient
doing in a setting in which you have to
serve the hand all of the characters
here want to kiss tywin's as while
Oberon definitely does not the right
rivalry between Oberyn and Mace Tyrell
is really funny and it shows the Stark
differences between what these
characters value so much one is a
bootlicker who will do anything for
Tywin while the other refuses to stand
when he enters the room and is lounging
in his seat these kind of scenarios the
writers put Oberyn into are so
intriguing because he sticks out much
more from these major differences it
amplifies his characteristics and
ideologies because they aren't normal in
this setting so they essentially stand
out like a sore thumb on the ideology
front his quick Snappy exchange with
Cersei about how Dorne doesn't despise
bastards creates a good conflicting
point for these characters to Bud heads
on so by putting Oberyn into settings
that fundamentally contrasts his
character and puts a spotlight onto what
makes him so original from a writing
point of view I think Oberyn is the best
example you can pull on as to how to
expertly set up and literally execute a
new character from every scene being
very productive and what they teach us
about Oberyn and his personality pulling
into the mess mysterious angle of his
character to make him more intriguing
contrasting him to certain characters
and settings to amplify his
characteristics and every twist he's
involved in perfectly utilizes him as a
character truly a Flawless character who
gets even better from an acting
standpoint from what Pedro Pascal brings
to the table you know what let's do a
little test do you think Pedro Pascal
won any awards for playing Oberyn
Martell or at the very least was
nominated the answer is surprisingly no
and not even any nominations but between
most of the characters in this season I
think Pedro Pascal's screen presence was
so infectious he nailed every
characteristic of Oberyn perfectly and
there was a lot to nail as I said before
every scene essentially showcases a new
characteristic so from an acting
standpoint it's really impressive to me
that Pedro Pascal was able to gracefully
portray each of these characteristics so
well this also requires a ton of range
from Pedra because he has to show heaps
of charisma confidence darkness and on
the opposite side of the spectrum he has
to be vulnerable if it wasn't for his
monologue with Tyrion he would have just
been a fun character but the scene
really cements him as an emotional
Powerhouse this kind of reminds me of
Robert Baratheon and most of his scenes
he's either being a strict ruler or a
memeing menace but the scene where he
gets real with Cersei and talks about
their marriage in detail really unveils
a Hidden Side to his character this is
what oberyn's cenotarian is to me and is
even better because it has a strong
progression throughout the entire scene
Pedro is able to build to the point of
sincere Sadness by first starting out in
a more playful mood he starts out
cracking some jokes and we first think
he's chastising Tyrion when he talks
about how people called him a devilish
baby I had twice the size of his body a
tail between his legs claws one red eye
private of both a girl and a boy then
slowly through his captivating monologue
he sympathizes and feels bad for Tyrion
to the point where he's chatting a tear
it's an extremely cathartic moment and
this low-key scene again shows oberyn's
more heartwarming side so overall for
his range it's showcased in Spades and
he's more than a badass Warrior for
another aspect about his acting that I
feel like is hard to achieve is the
amount of Charisma he portrays this is
an aspect that a lot of leading actors
can lack and it becomes very noticeable
if the actor doesn't feel confident in
the character if they lack this
confidence then their performance will
in turn become dull but what makes an
actor great is if they make you believe
they truly are that character and don't
come across as just reading lines this
requires a lot more involvement from the
actor and establishing more detailed
aspects like the voice of the character
inflection Cadence and the way they
physically hold themselves you can make
an easy distinction between great and
Bad actors if each one of these areas
aren't different for their characters
like Daniel Day Lewis essentially
rewrites his entire genetic makeup when
entering a new character and then on the
other hand the rock or Kevin Hart
essentially play themselves in every
role Pedro Pascal is over and feels very
distinct in each one of these areas his
voice has a unique accent given that
he's from Dorne his inflection is very
particular and regularly puts emphasis
on certain words for bigger dramatic
impacts and he has the Cadence of a
smooth River and then physically he
simultaneously feels like an Untouchable
God while also being very particular and
smart with how he moves like once you
really start to think about the work
Pedro Pascal is putting in here it's
like uncovering a deeper Iceberg from
all of this meticulous care being put
into the character he comes across as
very comfortable and he thoroughly
understands him so much to the point
that he occasionally adds in subtle
improvisations that made his character
more real and natural it's kind of hard
to identify improvisations without
access to the script but also a couple
examples the first one is my favorite
where Oberyn gracefully swipes his hand
through the wick of a candle which
boosted his badass meter by a huge
degree then this moment during tywin's
dialogue scene shows how Lively Oberyn
is some believe the sky is blue because
we live inside the eye of a blue-eyed
Giant
these spontaneous smaller actions
breathe life into the character a lot of
actors are just concerned about hitting
their marks for blocking and delivering
lines to the point that they feel
restricted in a way Petro Pascal
breathes instinctiveness into his
performance and through these
improvisations it communicates a visual
language of the character that is more
natural and is more natural because he's
actively engaging with his environment
which in turn AIDS its performance Petra
also seems like he's having a blast
playing the character in all of his
scenes and that comes through very
apparently going back to the opening of
this segment it's a shame that Pedro
Pascal's Oberyn didn't get any award
recognition which feels ironic because
of how iconic the character is this
literally put him on the map and I think
he deserved much more credit back then
to finish up the video I quickly want to
go into One external factor that makes
Oberyn even better at this point in Game
of Thrones we've essentially hit the
peak and in my opinion season 4 is the
best season every character is
completely fleshed out and they are all
amazing in their own way so introducing
a new character like Oberyn I feel like
would be a daunting task because you now
have to make a character that is of the
same caliber of our pre-existing ones
and the main external reason that makes
him inherently so interesting is the
fact that he's from Dorne he offers a
unique perspective in the already vast
world of Game of Thrones we've
essentially seen representation of the
different ways of life in most of
Westeros and out of all of them Dorne is
really unique the people that are
untamed and are resilient to normal
customs and seeing obern in the setting
of a place that doesn't communicate his
values creates some good conflict and
juxtaposition we get to see some
enrolled racism like the remarks the
Lannister soldiers make towards the
Oberyn this adds a lot of subtext about
how people view the dornish and this is
very important for how rich and huge the
world is now Dorn in the long run
doesn't end up being that important
given that the season 5 subplot was
terrible and their impact in the later
seasons was non-existent but Oberon in
season Force it's a good introductory
point for the dornish culture so if the
show happened to explore better plot
lines in Dorne a better book adaption of
Dorne maybe than the starting point sets
a good foundation to then explore later
on it's just too bad that it was kind of
wasted and even though it was it does
not diminish obrin's Brilliance in
season four thank you for watching and
I'm kind of curious about how well this
video performs because I still have more
Game of Thrones videos I can make and
want to do but if the interests around
the show and viewership is declining a
lot then I might prioritize making other
videos there is a series I want to start
at some point this year that I think
will be very fun and there's a lot of
potential there but yeah thank you for
watching and have a great day
thank you